أول ما قاله الجنرال كلارك بشأن
اتهام روسيا بأن أوكرانيا تستعد
لاستخدام ما يسمى بالقنبلة القذرة التي تحتوي على
مواد مشعة هو أن تحذير
روسيا يمكن في الواقع أن تتخذ تلك الخطوة الخطيرة
وهذا هو بالضبط ما هو عليه ، وهي
محاولة لتشتيت الانتباه وجلب
النقد والعدل.  أه وضع الفوضى في الحوار العام
حول أوكرانيا لا نعرف أه
كل الأسباب التي تجعل روسيا تقول
هذا لكنها بالتأكيد طريقة
لتغطية استعداداتها الخاصة ربما
لاستخدام سلاح نووي ربما في
منطقة كورسون ربما بالقول إنهم
ضربوا  أول من منع أوكرانيا من
القيام بذلك لا نعرفه ، لكن
ما نعرفه هو أنه ليس صحيحًا ، إنها
دعاية إنها معلومات
.  لقد مررت بنوع من
الدعاء لما يمكن أن يحدث بالأسلحة النووية
أعني الرئيس بوتين أه
بشكل أساسي أقول إن لدي كل الأسلحة
تحت تصرفي وسأفعل  أنا استخدمهم
للدفاع عن روسيا بالطبع وهذا يعني
الأسلحة النووية الاستراتيجية والتكتيكية والآن نحن ننتقل إلى
منطقة القنابل القذرة وبعبارة أخرى لقد
ذهبوا نوعًا ما ، كما تعلمون ، قاموا بتغطية
الواجهة البحرية في هذا الأمر ، لكنني أعتقد أن ما هو
مهم  هي روسيا وحتى
الاتحاد السوفيتي قبل ذلك استخدم هذه
التقنية ، إنها حقًا تقنية العلم الكاذب
حيث تتهم الشخص
الآخر بفعل ما تخطط
للقيام به بنفسك الآن لا نعرف لأننا سمعنا للتو
من عامة كل شيء وراء هذا
لكن أعتقد أنك تعرف باستمرار الحديث
عن الأسلحة والأسلحة النووية ، وهو
سلاح يمكن للقنبلة القذرة حقًا أن
تحدث الكثير من الفوضى وتؤثر حقًا على
السكان المدنيين وهذا أمر خطير للغاية